the next day I woke up early and got a  haircut I got the part in my hair which  I don't have right now came back home  and then I was looking through my closet  for a shirt that you know screamed 90s r  b music video type that's actually my  brother's shirt and he was never able to  wear that shirt again after that day the  location was my backyard I called my  brother I'm like yo can you come outside  real quick I want to film something  why you always lying oh my God stop  [ __ ] lying I didn't plan the moves I  was really just feeling it like you know  like in those old 90s R B videos where  it's just like a bop it just took over  my body I sat in the darkness for about  two hours maybe editing the sound the  volume so once I put it out I left my  phone alone you know the next day my  notifications were going so crazy from  Vine that I had to get a new phone  because my phone was overheating